Hey, so this is weird.
It seems that Donald Trump doesn't understand
the concept of per capita for the last 10
days or so.
Trump keeps bragging about how much the U.S.
is testing for the virus.
And every time he does, he's ignoring the
concept of per capita, or at least we thought
he was ignoring the concept of per capita
because it wasn't politically convenient.
But based on yesterday's press conference,
I'm increasingly thinking Trump doesn't understand
what per capita means.
Per capita, of course, is when you adjust
numbers for the size of a population.
So if I say to you, you know, the United States
and Colombia both gave away $100 million to
people in stimulus money per capita in the
U.S., that's twenty nine cents per person.
In Colombia, it's $2 per person because Colombia
and the U.S. have different populations.
If we say, you know, we did a million corona
virus tests and South Korea did 500000, might
sound like we did more.
But per capita, South Korea did way more because
South Korea's population is much smaller than
ours.
We have three hundred and forty million people
in the U.S.. South Korea has about 50 million
people.
So check this out yesterday.
REPORTER You, HAMISH
Alcindor asked Trump about this.
And Trump says we're testing more than anyone
and you meet raises the issue of per capita
and Trump doesn't seem to get it.
He wrongly states the population of Seoul,
South Korea.
He talks about how we have rural areas in
the United States and it only gets funnier.
And by funnier, I mean more tragic because
we laugh to avoid crying in these difficult
times.
Take a look at the first part of the video.
Mr. President, you said several times that
the United States has ramped up testing, but
the United States is still not testing per
capita.
As many read as many people as other countries
like South Korea.
Why is that?
And when do you think that that number will
be on par with other countries?
Well, it's very much on par.
Look, look what per capita we have areas of
country that's very wide.
I know South Korea better than anybody.
It's a very tight you know, how many people
are in Seoul.
Do you know how big the city of Seoul is?
Thirty eight million people.
Okay.
So that's like 10 seconds from Trump.
And there are just so many things to look
at there.
Trump mentions.
Hey, but hold on a second.
We have rural areas in the United States and
Seoul.
South Korea is really dense per capita accounts
for the population.
That's the point of per capita.
Trump is acting like the fact that we have
rural areas means we are testing more per
capita.
No, we're talking about how much are we testing
relative to the population, which includes
rural areas and densely populated areas.
Yemi is at least trying to talk about per
capita.
Then Trump says he knows South.
Area better than anyone.
Which is another one of those hyperbolic lies.
But then again, immediately he misstates the
population of Seoul, saying Seoul has a population
of 38 million for a guy who knows the most
about South Korea.
It's
weird not to know the population of Seoul.
So it didn't sound right when Trump said 38
million.
I looked it up.
Seoul's population is only 9 million, almost
10 million.
So I thought, well, maybe Trump was referring
to the metro area, the Seoul metro area.
But that's only 25 million.
So I thought, well, maybe Trump meant all
of South Korea has 38 million.
But no, as I mentioned earlier, South Korea
has about 51 million people.
So then and this is just too funny.
If you Google Seoul, South Korea, this quick
facts, things thing pops up and it says 38
M, but that's the elevation of Seoul, 38 meters
above sea level or 125 feet.
Is it possible Trump is confusing population
and elevation or is he just a moron who doesn't
know anything?
And South Korea is not.
He's not actually an expert in South
Korea and he doesn't understand the concept
of per capita.
Maybe that's the most likely explanation.
You be the judge.
Here's the rest of the back and forth with
journalist you, Mitch Alcindor.
That's bigger than anything.
We have 38 million people hold tightly wound
together.
We have vast farmlands.
We have vast areas where they don't have much
of a problem.
In some cases, I have no problem whatsoever.
We have done more tests.
What I didn't I didn't talk about per capita.
We have done more tests by far than any country
in the world by far.
Our testing is also better than any country
in the world.
So again, Trump talking about how, hey, but
we have rural areas, but again, per capita
accounts for the total population and the
number of tests adjusted to the size of that
population.
Imagine having a president.